you go to film School how do you get
that first movie well my first one I
shot in India
um called praying with anger which
nobody saw and then my second movie
which nobody saw except me a robin she
was very kind Robin and some of my
family do you remember that night all my
cousins what was the second movie is it
called wide awake with that mirror
maximum it was a Rosie O'Donnell thing
yeah Rosie thing what was the premise
there was it one of those weird sort of
Eerie movies that you do no no I hadn't
really uh done that figured that out yet
and so it was just kind of reaching and
that one was uh I went to Catholic
school for 10 years so I made a movie
about that how do you get Miramax to
bank on a film student how do you get
those guys involved
screenplay yeah you wrote it I wrote it
and then they said yeah we'll make it
for this amount of money how long does
it take to write a screenplay about
eight months eight months yeah how long
before you get the idea well I have the
idea and it has to sit for a while so
that I know it's not gonna disappear on
me because it takes two years to make
the movie so I don't want it to all
right six cents yes you get the idea
right so you sit down in your house and
you go I'm going to write a screenplay
and you got to do that for eight months
right
well that one took a year what do you
write on a computer sometimes sometimes
they write a long hand long hand yeah
now that's interesting it's more freeing
it won't be as you know finished but you
get a lot more kind of flow so when you
come up with a cool idea like that then
you write for a year and you sell that
to a studio that idea and they pay you
to write the movie well yes the you know
when you write it in advance it's called
unspec which is you know on speculation
so no you know if it's not good no one's
going to pay you anything see oh really
you took your year and you did it but
then you have great power if it turns
out to be great why does it take a year
for you to write the script I mean I
wasn't a very good writer so it took me
a long time to learn how to that was
when I was learning how to write and I
actually wrote um the adaptation of
Stuart Little in that same year so oh
braggard I guess you learned a lot I
forgot about that that actually was the
thing I think that kind of you know
because I was I did that for my baby at
the time and I think that really taught
me how to kind of not be so precious
just on the side he wrote Stuart Little
right she just throws that one off you
have to do the Bruce Willis thing that
makes like a hundred million or
something how much did that make well
worldwide maybe about 670 million wow
right out of the box almost a billion
dollars that's pretty good what's
motivating you at this time you just
love making movies well you know it's
the same thing that you know after the
mirror Max thing when it's um when there
was you know you had nothing the phone's
not ringing and it's complete failure
it's the same as it is now which is the
only thing you do it for is the love of
Storytelling